packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
now it's all about making it easy
[Music]
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time you have
effectively and the one thing that can
really help you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes
one of my favorites is meatballs in
fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
Lifesaver it means you never have to
compromise on Flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off your onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs a classic way but the exciting
part
is actually cook them in coconut milk
and it gives a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft Rich Sumptuous
meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together closer
the slices the finer the onions
Pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop
I want the onions nice and fine because
I want some finesse to these meatballs
The Secret of a really good meatball is
the texture getting that balance right
between the minced beef the bread crumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple cloves of
garlic slice of garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in a little touch of
salt and pepper
[Music]
with your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of Pat it out that salt
and pepper
for me
a good meatball is all about the the
softness the texture of that Rich beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again I've
got some really nice dried chili flakes
I'm going to season the onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
I'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice slightly doughy
texture but it lightens the texture of
the meatball
place that in
add your onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
the problem with making them too small
is the fact that they dry out quickly
just the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
getting a really nice Thai squeeze that
stops IT from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom look at that pan nice and hot
Touch of olive oil in there
place them
the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a palette knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coriander seeds slightly spicy
and peppery obviously give a really nice
flavor to the coconut milk and next some
cardamon seeds three or four onto the
board knife on
and no touch on turmeric into the center
of the pan that's going to give it a
really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch cinnamon
and all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them Infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of Beat It
Down that starts to release all that
lovely sort of fragrance I know
someone's just let off the most amazing
fragrant air freshener in the lemongrass
finally some fresh ginger
peel and slice nice and thinly
time now
to turn them over
and let the other half for a wonderful
flavor
chicken stock in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
I want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of a meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's going to cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
then simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
[Music]
touch them with your finger they should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gas off I'm gonna finish it off with
something light and fresh zest of lime
but I want the zest
on top of the meatball so we'll cut
through that richness
and then finally
squeeze fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice zesty
amazing taste
stirring the juice
it's got that kick in that vibrant taste
now exciting power
when you come to serve it be generous
with that coconut broth tilt the pan get
a good couple of ladles of a broth in
meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very delicious way of
eating a old-fashioned meatball and
bringing it into the 21st century and
they're just as good cooked from Frozen
as well
[Music]
[Applause]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself here are
three more recipes all based on my
delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
[Music]
first up beef meatballs with ariketti
kale and pine nuts
[Applause]
[Music]
eat balls to Hot Oil
Brown
meanwhile cook origetti pasta
then add chopped garlic to the meatballs
and shredded kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which Cooks in
minutes
cabbage is a great alternative if you
can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam through
when the pasta is cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs
season
then finish with sweet buttery pine nuts
and grated fresh parmesan cheese
meatballs with other Kitty kale and pine
nuts from meatballs to meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly Toasted Roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear off chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the Tangy salsa sliced sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chopped fresh coriander
season and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a Flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
[Music]
my final super easy meatball recipe is
fiery meatball soup
[Music]
fried chopped onion and finely slice
garlic in hot olive oil
cumin seeds for warmth
and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out
once the meatballs are browned add hot
chili paste for a spicy kick tinned
tomatoes
dried oregano and a liter of beef stock
then simmer
next add sweet corn
and chopped courgettes
[Music]
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers chop
fresh coriander and crushed tortilla
chips
a one-pot meatball wonder that really
packs a punch fiery meatball soup
one versatile meatball recipe four
deliciously different dishes food that's
certain to make your life in the kitchen
easier and stress-free amazing whether
you're making great food to freeze or to
take straight to the table you need to
know how to shop for the best
ingredients next up my shopping guide to
oils
[Music]
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter The
Taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for
flower oil is a good value all-rounder
nice and light for frying bacon in
dressings and spicy dishes
ground nuts or peanut oil is great for
cooking on high heat as it gets really
hot without burning
flavor some sweet and nutty oil perfect
sprinkled over Asian dishes before
serving
rapeseed oil is a healthier choice for
using in salads
I love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
it's brilliant for salad dressings and
it gives cakes a distinctive flavor
but the oil I used most in my cooking is
olive oil
[Music]
to find some of the best olive oils sold
in Britain you have to go to one of the
most unlikely places
an electrical shop in London's East End
turkish-born Mehmet morat has olive oil
in his blood my families produce this
olive oil for centuries what he doesn't
know about it isn't worth knowing
the very best extra virgin olive oil is
first cold pressed it's actually pressed
by Stone and then it's put for a
centrifugal spinner which spins out all
the bitter Waters and then you've got
your pure olive oil cold pressed olive
oil and you've got to taste it to
believe it
pour a little sample
slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth
with it and then swallow it will go down
like fruit juice and it will leave no
grease in a solar oiliness in your mouth
whatsoever
absolutely Sensational beautiful
my favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room temperature rub
some wild oregano into it and get some
fresh crusty bread and just dip it
there's food on its own don't eat
anything else
[Music]
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next on my guide to making it easy I'll
be creating a sweet treat to drool over
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around but first
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here are
three more Kitchen Essentials
whisk spoon and spatula
these three items are so cheap yet they
are so important to Great home cooking
a whisk
I was more control when you've got
something whisking in your hand you can
gauge it so much better than you can if
it's on an electric mixer
the bigger the balloon on your hand
whisk the faster it will whip as it
draws in more air Wooden Spoons don't
scratch pans they should be washed by
hand spatulas are indispensable for
baking or mixing
sure it's heat resistant so it doesn't
melt but more importantly phenomenal for
making
omelettes great with scrambled eggs and
you waste nothing because the spatula
almost cleans the bowl instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro
and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondes
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
gently melt that butter
caster sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make a
little well in the middle
and sort of whisk you can see it's
already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that
a really good mix
[Music]
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk in two whole eggs
just give a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yes so
simple whisk in the eggs looking for
that nice sort of Rich texture smooth
paste
see why we call these blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in then half a teaspoon of baking
soda
that aerates the mixture and gives it
that little tartness you'll see this
sort of Rise instantly the minute they
hit the oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half a flour end
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost go nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages it stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon next
I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondes dried
cranberries
they bake beautifully but it gives the
Blondie a really nice sort of chewy
sweetness in the center next and white
chocolate
I'm not going to grate it just chop it
up just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
chocolate in lovely fold that in I want
a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
that chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now a bacon tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
creased proof
allows me to maximize on the white
chocolate inside the mix no grease with
paper the chocolate can melt and almost
stick to the tray so the paper is just a
really nice insurance policy secondly we
want that rise and that sort of
crispness now with the mix get your
spatula go all the way around I don't
want to see anything left in that bowl
position the ball over your tray
nice and carefully
lovely
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of the spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp all that soft
gooeyness in the center
bake your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
[Music]
that smells incredible
look at that crisp Edge on the outside
and that sort of soft gooey Center leave
that to cool down and it's going to sort
of firm up and wrinkle but it'll stay
nice and gooey in the center once it's
cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
mouth-watering blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips to make your life easier make sure
you make the most of your freezer my tip
for amazing tuna carpaccio is to freeze
it first and it will slice beautifully
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine and freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
[Music]
this
when you freeze soups or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
[Music]
for a cheap homemade ice cream buy a
high quality vanilla ice cream and make
it your own by mixing in berries
chocolate or my favorite rum and boozy
raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
okay now it's all about special salads
and fabulous fruits perfect for special
occasions
cooking at home for special occasions
falls into two camps sit down Affairs
where the food's a bit more formal
and relaxed parties where dishes are
laid out and people can choose what they
want to eat and when
if you're cooking for a party always
make dishes that are colorful vibrant
and exciting to eat
so you'll grab your guest attention and
really wow their taste buds my first
dish has plenty of attitude enough for
any special occasion a flavor packed
green papaya salad this is a great
seller to serve at a party it's
delicious and robust enough to last the
whole evening without wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp you can buy them anywhere
they smell almost sort of the seabed
into the pest and water for this salad
inspired by my travels across Thailand
I'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste there's a little salt in
there in
just break them up this paste is like a
staple ingredient in Thailand that's
what we're looking for almost
powder right next just one clove of
garlic
slice up the garlic
and get that into the pest and water
bird's eye chili incredibly hot powerful
but wow it does give an amazing kick to
the pace
[Music]
in
to the mix
now a couple tablespoons of brown caster
sugar
that softens the blow with a chili and
then just to get that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
Tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet paste one tablespoon in
fish sauce
now it's got that almost sort of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense two tablespoons and bring that
together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice
in half
Another Touch of sort of tartness
[Music]
the paste is nice and thick and fragrant
but it's got the heat the sourness the
tartness
incredible
Green Papaya stand it up give it a
little peel you can find Green Papaya in
local Asian shops and bigger
supermarkets and as it doesn't world
like more delicate Veg it's perfect for
robust salads like this a great hit
look
that's what I want these thin slivers
next a nice rich sweet banana shallot
[Music]
nice some carrot
Cara gives it another texture
now nipple that and mix it
finish that off with Thai Basil and
fresh coriander
Thai Basil is a much more fragrant basil
it's stronger and it's slightly thicker
as well
like papaya and Tamarind paste you can
get Thai Basil in good supermarkets and
independent Asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan on
and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
indigo
roll them around the pan
gas off
just took them out
for the exciting Palm I'm going to dress
the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and then finally a nice General
sprinkling roasted nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust
green papaya salad so easy to make and
guaranteed not to go limp a perfect
party salad and with such incredible
colors textures and bold exciting
flavors it's sure to grab your guest
attention when you're putting together a
feast for the family or friends it's
great to have some bulletproof salads in
your cooking repertoire here are three
more of my favorites to set you up
first my delicious chopped salad
thank you
sliced cherry tomatoes in half and add
to the Bowl
along with chopped red pepper
and finely dice shallots
next slice salami into strips
and add follow with nutty chickpeas
and smooth Edam cheese cut into
matchsticks building up different tastes
textures and flavors as you go next add
chicory for a deliciously bitter bite
then chop crisp romaine lettuce
and add for the dressing finely chopped
garlic
add Cherry vinegar a shake a spicy
Worcestershire sauce cast the sugar
and olive oil
then simply whisk
pour the dressing over the salad and mix
so that everything is Thoroughly coated
finally sprinkle with dried oregano for
an aromatic finish
I sell it so easy if you can chop you
can make it with such delicious results
it has to be tasted to be believed
[Music]
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bowl of
garlic in foil and roast it in a hot
oven
next add top and tail green beans to
salted boiling water
and cook for just a couple of minutes
this is called blanching and keeps the
beans deliciously crunchy
strain the beans
and refreshing cold water this tops the
cooking process so to stay crisp and
green
[Music]
next remove your garlic from the oven
off the head
squeeze out all the Glorious garlic
which has gone creamy mellow and divine
in the oven
[Music]
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of Dijon mustard and sweet
runny honey
season
and pour in a good lug of olive oil then
whisk
at the crunchy blanched green beans
and topped with toasted almonds for a
lovely nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well
and serve
Heavenly mustard vinaigrette with a hit
of mellow roast garlic stunning green
beans dressed to perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
Herb salad
[Music]
add free lentils to vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and boil for 15
minutes
free lentils are perfect for sellers
they have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture
next chop sweet red peppers and place on
a baking tray
along with diced courgette
drizzle over olive oil
season and roast in a hot oven
to assemble the salad place the drain
lentils in a large bowl
and add olive oil
[Music]
and chop some blush tomatoes
the roasted red peppers and courgettes
from the oven and add
foreign
avocado as its delicious creamy flesh
give this salad a lovely contrast
[Music]
then for a big Herby hit chop a handful
of chives and basil
and add
squeeze over lemon juice and mix
earthy aromatic and packed full of
goodness absolutely stunning served with
roasted meats and fish or perfect eaten
just by itself
three incredible salads all bursting
with flavor color and health so quick
and easy to prep and utterly delicious
you'll be making them every day not just
on a special occasion nice
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course coming up I'll be using fabulous
fruits to create a show-stopping dessert
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box but first the key to dishes
that really impress is amazingly fresh
ingredients and it's essential to get
the best for your money when you're out
shopping so make sure whatever you're
buying it looks smells and feels really
good and if you get the chance and taste
it before you buy it
[Music]
a great tasting salad starts with
fantastic salad leaves and when it comes
to all things green there's little Dr
Steve rothall doesn't know
I think I am obsessed with salad I'm
obsessed primarily with Watercress that
that's in my heart because you know I've
got a PhD in watercress
a doctorate and salad we should all take
a leaf Harry's book then he's not only
been studying salad leaves for over 30
years he's been grown them so he really
knows he's rocket from his Romaine
[Music]
there are literally thousands of
varieties of salad things like Batavian
lettuce red vein spinach wild Rockette
Sorrel we grow virtually everything
outdoors and and we follow the seasons
so we're not forcing the leaves we don't
give them too much fertilizer or
irrigation we try to grow them a little
bit slower and that's the way to get the
best flavor and the best quality of leaf
we'll Harvest a crop cut it in the
morning and it's then on the road going
out to customers to be on the Shelf the
next day this is a great Leaf baby leaf
spinach and we call it baby Leaf you
know quite literally because we cut it
when it's still in a baby stage
these are baby pea shoots we'll put
something like three or four hundred pea
seeds into the seed bed and then in as
little as 12-14 days they've grown to a
sort of a crop like this they've got the
flavor of fresh peas a bit of sweetness
and they've got a really nice soft
velvety Leaf texture
this is baby Watercress which is my
favorite salad crop of them all
Watercress is special because by
definition it's grown in pure flowing
water fresh water grass has got that
fantastic pungent peppery flavor
in Victorian London it was known as Poor
Man's bread whereby a lot of workers
would start the day with a Watercress
sandwich and if they couldn't afford
bread they just ate the Watercress
straight it is an amazing full of flavor
I can't eat enough salad obsessed
Steve's spot on there's hundreds of
salad leaves available with different
textures tastes and colors here are five
my favorite everyday salad leaves and
don't forget some of them are delicious
cooked too
little gem sweet and crisp and an
amazingly dense heart these mini cos
lettuces are great simply braised in the
oven or use the leaves as Scoops for a
delicious chili beef filling
mustard leaves pungent spicy and full of
vitamin C these are a staple in Asian
dishes and are fantastic stir-fried or
steamed
Lamb's Leaf full of Tangy flavor and
with Incredible springy stems great for
hearty Robo salads or simply paired with
fish for a healthier simple supper
rocket these distinctive peppery leaves
are actually classed as a herb and are
perfect in soups or with fruits and are
full of iron
[Music]
finely chicory or ondive these tightly
packed red or white leaves have a
deliciously bitter taste and are great
wrapped in ham or alongside sharp blue
cheeses I think when you're shopping for
salads you kind of shop with your eyes
if it looks fresh and healthy tasty it
is you want to look for bright colors I
like to see leaves with a bit of
moisture on them
Summers like to be kept cold and moist
basically So when you buy a pack of
salad put it in the fridge and if you
don't use it all in one go roll up the
bag to exclude Surplus air put it back
in the fridge keep it cold there's so
much choice of writing out there I
really do think people should be more
adventurous in their choice of salads
here both what they choose to try and
eat and and what they do with them so
get yourself some ingredients use them
boldly and your salad leaves can really
take Center Stage
tricks the trade and kitchen tips
scallops are a fantastic ingredient when
you want a special salad that really
impresses here's how to prepare them do
not be intimidated trying to get the
scallop out I'm going to show you how
easy it is to take them out and how much
more exciting it is to get them fresh in
the Shell so just basically dessert
spoon and a blunt knife
put the knife in
to the bottom and you just twist
open
Tilt The Knife up so it doesn't cut into
the scallop meat run the knife from the
top
to the base
off with the lid no Flesh on there
and then from there that's called the
scallop skirt all you do is just peel
that forward and get the spoon to run
down the back of the shell and the idea
is to remove that little bit of muscle
that holds the scallop onto the bottom
shelf bang it pops out that's the top
the small side of the bottom
there's the muscle there and your thumb
just slides neatly in there and run your
fingers around and you just pop out
scallop
and look
bang beautiful this bit here is called a
skirt no use doesn't taste anything now
that's the coral you can slice that off
dry it in the oven and use it as a
powder for your risottos or even
seasoning fish with but that's the money
these just need to be rinsed under cold
water dried and ready for the pan
tomatoes are another salad staple here's
how to skin them for extra refinement
score each one with a cross at the
bottom blanching boiling water for a
minute
then shot them in cold water and the
Skins will easily peel away
pomegranates are a fabulous fruit for
adding glamor to salads or desserts the
trick to getting the seeds out slice in
half lent ways make slits around the
edge turn upside down over a bowl and
using a large spoon whack as hard as you
can to release the seeds
to take fabulous fruit puts the next
level my tip is to add sophisticated
cornells of ice cream or lemon
mascarpone
simply dip two metal spoons in hot water
scoop
shape and add
[Music]
and after baking never throw out your
leftover pastry it's easily transformed
into grapefruit or savory party nibbles
roll out
great parmesan or sprinkle over your
favorite fruit
roll
and then just slice and bake
[Music]
as any chef knows at the end of a meal
you want to leave your guests on a high
with a spectacular dessert
[Music]
so when you're cooking for a special
occasion and want to make an impact it's
great to have a fabulous fruit dessert
up your sleeve
my last recipe looks Sensational and
tastes just as good
raspberry milfoy
desserts should always have that wow
factor and this dish is incredibly
simple to prepare but it tastes and
looks absolutely stunning
[Music]
first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous for pastry
now a non-stick
baking tray and just lay the puff pastry
on the tray I want to get the top of the
puff pastry caramelized I'm going to
dust it in icing sugar
means a thousand layers
just lightly dust the top of the puff
pastry with icing sugar
we're going to start off in a hot oven
at 220.
for the first six or seven minutes and
then 10 minutes at 190 into the oven
care for the filling
fresh vanilla
creaming
and start whisking
want the cream whisked nice and thick
but look to all that nice fresh vanilla
seeds in there next
a nice scraping of orange zest
orange liqueur
don't whisk that in fold it in
and that stops the cream from separating
lovely
now take that out of the bowl
and put it into a Piping Bag unwrap over
your hands
in a way that you're trading those
little pocket
snip off the end
nozzle
in
load up
the bag
just twist slowly
There's No Air
the bag
it's nice and full
and firm nice chill your gorgeous
vanilla and orange cream in the fridge
until you're ready to pipe it
wow
that
is beautiful there's the layers there
that's the the Milford gently lift it up
onto the board
I'll slide into three
serrated edge knife
beautiful start deciding on how you're
going to layer it
that bit there that's nice and firm for
my base that's nice and decorative for
the top and that bit there for the
middle
take out your cream
and put a little touch of cream there
and that just sticks that down
stops it from sliding
pipe very carefully
a nice thin layer of cream around the
outside and come back into the middle
beautiful
now the rest was
sit them two by two
now this layer I'll turn it upside down
and put the caramelized pile of pastry
on top of the raspberries every time I
get to put one of these together it's
like a sort of little jewelry box again
cream
squeeze
on the back of the bag
so you've got control
they're asked with
two by two
[Music]
I just want to put another layer of
cream on top those rafts with because I
want some height with my final layer
oh I just want to dive in there
put the lid on it
[Music]
push that down
there you have a beautiful stunning
simple mil foreign
to die for
and like all the dishes in my ultimate
cookery course I guarantee it will taste
as Sensational as it looks
[Music]
good
I've now shown you 100 recipes to stake
your life on smells
amazing simple and accessible dishes
look at that to give you confidence in
the kitchen hold the drum and slice
straight through and help cook yourself
into a better Chef really important to
season the mints before you cook it I've
shared essential tips and Insider
knowledge they don't actually smell much
but the flavor they give off is
extraordinary on everything from
shopping for great ingredients don't be
fine get your nose right into it to my
kitchen equipment Essentials The Secret
of brazing is having a really nice thick
durable pan and my ultimate cooking
lessons key mantras to make you Fearless
in the kitchen stripping away all the
complexity so you can whip up tasty and
delicious dishes with ease just finish
it with a little tablespoon of that
sauce and most importantly learn to
enjoy cooking at home incredible many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
what are you waiting for go on get
cooking